that was gum resumes that's my new name
might when my mom gave birth to me she
was like I will name him she was
actually just possessed by Satan who
would have thought look how nice I
became sorry I dream about you but
cheese every night so this has a
Halloween edition we're a little late on
that train but I never go on trains ha
jokes are funny welcome to the wonderful
world of jokes all right so I'm this
Halloween man all right I'm like oh god
the skeleton oh they gave me speed ha ha
ha ha
how do I turbo again [ __ ] ha ha ha
[ __ ] oh god what is happening here
don't you dead no one's gonna push me
off this pram no one is pushing me off
the stretch that's right where's why am
i not number one mo what pull the
crapper mission beat the clock where's
the clock I'm ready to beat disease I
got you I got you
later that's amazing oh [ __ ] Sam pie
I know I can just keep [ __ ] these
out when I'm dead it's like where are
you going base for bad don't leave me
I'm lonely
oh Jesus I have a [ __ ] pot Luck's
what that's awesome what is happening
over here guys don't care I have a but
Lex
no no what happened to my back legs damn
it
almost number one almost number one yeah
I hate you ah Oh what how did that
happen Oh Oh get your late give me so
awesome that's what I'm talking Brad
high five high five high five
I'll have any friends don't judge all
right
Jesus next mission Oh God not the storms
Oh God
God why naked why do you test me gosh I
have a shovel so no one's gonna stop me
and my shovel
maybe this card storm may I
you you're sad to do it didn't ya huh
I'm back I'm back all right all right
we're good okay I'm nice place don't
even worry about it what what the hell
without God what the hell literally
later noobs oh god what I don't know
what happened he's crazy he's crazy
trying to kill me why would they try to
kill me I'm so [ __ ] nice what what
are you doing buddy
Oh pal Iike this put a helicopter there
yeah I'm number one I'm number two damn
it until you've chopped the police
within battle-ax
and you haven't lived man number one so
badass spider bike spider bike here we
go oh god this is a new map
Jesus this is not a road bro you should
change the name of the game pray don't
tell me what to do this is so intense
kick him that was awesome
kick him if you wanna be happy for the
rest of your life kick away a bike
victus reasons I wish my mom was here to
see this she would be so okay I pearl of
any help
what's the mission race what is
happening over there no you're mean stop
it stop it red card cabron step back
look what your dad go back to Canada I
place a c4 on him hey buddy
christmas comes early this year [ __ ]
wait i have what a harpoon oh god
terrible idea terrible idea how do I
link disengage all right here we go all
right this will be awesome
nice nice one there we go this'll do it
damn it maybe not there we go he's fine
really
you're not fine brother what if I got
what I did
now don't flag me in with you yeah that
[ __ ]
what is that car doing number one baby
number two maybe no you're not gonna do
that
that's right [ __ ] no go back to
Sweden I was racist against myself great
we did it
wait so intense this game you guys have
no idea you played it no it's okay
hi buddy hey buddy hey buddy
okay you want a present it's free from
the only pay day ah [ __ ] hey man you're
my best friend how are you doing buddy
aah what are you doing did you not hear
me get your number - that's what you get
for [ __ ] big games hey buddy how you
doing you like traffic wait aren't you
kiss I never knew that didn't really
work out what what kind of cap are you
come here what oh we flew together
that's Oh God why don't you suck my ass
suck it suck it that's rough oh it's so
much easier when they learn how to do
hey there buddy do you have a mom to
talk about my ass huh
and I want us every time for me and my
ass oh god whatever [ __ ] alright but
this game is a blast to play I hope
you're a psycho watching if you did it I
like it I will see you froze in the next
one as always stay awesome ride